thanks to babel a language learning app
for sponsoring this episode
if you're interested in growing your
language skills microcosmos viewers get
up to 65
off when you sign up using our link in
the description
[Laughter]
this algae is stressed and we can tell
it's stressed because it's doing
something that
you might also do when you find yourself
in a difficult situation
it's turning red but while blushing
brightly for everyone to see
might make your situation worse this
algae can do
something else that sounds honestly very
appealing
it can curl up in a ball and just wait
out the worst of it
this algae is called hematococcus and it
is not
physiologically speaking turning red
through these same mechanisms that you
and i do
when we are stressed and blushing we
flush with blood meanwhile the
hematococcus
does not have blood but depending on the
state of your ancient greek you might
recognize
its name translates loosely to
bloodberries
a name that seems fitting for a round
reddish organism like this one
but as poetically sanguinary as the name
is
hepatococcus flushes with something else
altogether
a chemical we can see traveling through
the algae
and up the food chain until it winds up
on our own plates but before we get to
the dinner table
let us talk about where we got our
hematococcus
from a centuries-old cemetery in warsaw
poland filled with beautiful sculptures
and bird baths for james our master of
microscopes it is important to respect
the tombs there
so don't worry these microbes don't have
particularly spooky origins
he's there for the bird baths where the
algae lines the surfaces like rust the
hematococcus likely arrived at the
birdbath thanks to the birds themselves
and there it would have remained until
maybe another bird came along
except this time your favorite microbe
hunter came
first in addition to bird baths
hematococcus are often found in
transient pools of fresh water like
puddles after a rainfall and as you can
see on your screen
not all hematococcus are red plenty of
them are green
which makes sense because hematococcus
is a member of the phylum
chlorophyta and that phylum is full of
many
other unicellular green algae like the
volvox
and as an algae hematococcus are green
photosynthetic and very easy to eat
which makes them a simple solid
foundation for an ecosystem
but even seemingly simple creatures have
requests of the world around them
whether that's for certain levels of
light or a particular
temperature and if you were to say go to
a hotel and your
room was a hundred degrees you got a few
solid options to fix that problem
you could find a thermostat and if that
doesn't work you could complain to the
manager
or even just go find another place to
stay
but those are not great options for the
hematococcus
there's no thermostat to change there's
no manager to call and if the
temperature gets too high
there's only so much a single celled
body can do to survive
so instead the hematococcus does what
i'm sure many of us wish we could do
when we were in an uncomfortable
situation
it takes a little bit of a break forming
a cyst
that allows it to rest and survive until
conditions are good again
when you're looking at this mixture of
hematococcus you are looking at a
gathering of algae in different phases
of their lives
the most active ones are called
macrozoids or
zoa spores they might be shaped like
spheres ellipsoids or even
pears and they are encased in a thick
gelatinous
wall with two flagella extending out in
front
to zip the algae around but most
importantly here at this stage the algae
is green the hematococcus rarely
reproduces sexually
and when it's a macrozoid it divides
rapidly
forming around 2 to 32 copies of itself
but it makes sense to move around and
make more of yourself when conditions
are good
what happens though when you're in a
comfortable pool of water one day
and in much more dire straits the next
well for the hematococcus this is the
point at which it all begins to change
the algae sheds its flagella layers up
its wall
and shifts into a ball this is the
hematococcus
as a palmella a resting cell
but if stress has taught me anything
it's that things can always get worse
and for this little cell it can get
hotter or saltier
just too bright and when that happens
the palmella morphs
into an aplanospore its walls become
even heavier duties shielding it from
the outside but
most striking this is when the
hematococcus becomes red
the red is practical the product of a
chemical called astaxanthin
astaxanthin is a carotenoid a type of
reddish yellow pigment found in plants
and microbes
but it's more than just a pretty color
astaxanthin is an extremely powerful
antioxidant protecting the cyst from
potential damage
as it rests you've probably seen
astaxanthin in real life except you
might not have called it that
you might have just called it pink or
salmon pink
astaxanthin is found in plants fungi
bacteria
and yes in algae and hematococcus is
considered to be one of the best natural
producers of astaxanthin
able to produce up to five percent of
its dry weight in astaxanthin
for comparison another astaxanthin
producing algae called chlorella
makes about 0.001 percent of its dry
weight in astaxanthin
and the reason we find astaxanthin in so
many animals is because
algae make for good food whether you are
a shrimp
a salmon or a flamingo it's striking
that the color we call salmon pink
is a sign of both the salmon's
contentment
and the algae's demise perhaps we should
start calling it hematococcus pink
instead
an acknowledgment of the work of the
hematococcus
which endures so long after its death
it would be a fitting tribute after all
to a color you might have eaten a few
times yourself
the salmon sure which might have fed on
synthetic astaxanthin or on algae
but even the chicken eggs you buy might
have gotten their yolk color
boosted by algae added to chicken feed
astaxanthin has its uses outside of our
food
whether in our cosmetics or
nutraceuticals
and while much of that is synthetic a
copy we've learned to make by studying
the chemistry of astaxanthin
there's also a push in the market for
natural products
a push that has led to renewed interest
in the hematococcus algae
and its wondrous ability to produce its
own astaxanthin
but for the hematococcus that's just
something weird going on in the outside
world a factor
far beyond its control and its interest
whatever comes its way whether it's a
scientist a bird or a fish
all the hematococcus is concerned with
is its own survival
what belongs to the algae will one day
belong to another organism
passed on through chemistry and made
into something new
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
babel for sponsoring this episode of
journey to the microcosmos
babel is a language learning app that
helps you use a new language in real
life situations after only
5 hours of practice and it offers
lessons in 14
languages whether you want to travel
somewhere new and be able to speak the
language when you get there
or you're just looking for some
self-improvement that you can do from
the comfort of your couch
babel courses are professionally
designed by language experts who take
into account your native language
and it will teach you vocabulary and
grammar skills that you can use in real
life situations like
asking for directions or ordering at a
restaurant
and babel even has a podcast short
stories
games and new live virtual classes from
certified teachers
so you can learn in whatever format
works for you as a micro cosmos viewer
you'll get up to 65 percent off if you
download babel
and sign up by clicking the link in the
description
all the folks on the screen right now
they are our patreon patrons
and if you are one of those people the
microcosmos team is
very grateful and we just want to say
thanks if you would like to become a
microcosmos patron you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro where you can also find
some really good stuff that we've got
only for our patrons
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you